today we are doing an original iPhone
verse iPhone 10 let's go take some
photos and compare the two it's gonna be
very interesting comparison considering
there's no front facing camera there's
no video there's really just one single
tiny little camera can you see that look
at that little baby okay from the
beginning
[Music]
[Applause]
can you believe this what I've got in my
hand right now
afraid we're gonna see this crack today
I almost dropped it the other day when I
was opening the bond if you drop it I'll
slap it into the sand okay
would your bent take a picture of my
beautiful body I mean come on
okay picture of Ed original iPhone wow
that was a very slow shot now here's a
picture of Jonah taking a picture the
original iPhone didn't have video or a
front-facing camera so this is how we
had to take selfies this was my method I
still got it
I look just as young as I did ten years
ago so this would be a comparison
between the first iPhone back camera and
new iPhone front-facing camera since I
can see myself back facing selfie
[Music]
I just went to hit home button
there's no home button this home button
was revolutionary so I had a wardrobe
change to make it look like might be
roll widths from several different days
if using the phone but that's silly and
I just changed my clothes for no reason
but now we're gonna go and we're gonna
coffee and I'm gonna try to use Apple
pay I don't think the breasts are look
at the joke okay looks like 9 that a
funny joke but this phone is 11 years
old this phone is older than the
children sitting in the corner ok here's
a shot of my coffee with the iPhone 10
so I got to figure out the good focal
length so that it's actually gonna be in
focus which is just I don't think a
single picture I've taken today is put
in focus so it takes so long okay that's
why hey you can zoom
as Chris it doesn't look bad but it
doesn't look good
a man
okay look at this they're the photos do
tend to run a little bit on the darker
side which is kind of cool because
nothing really is ever overexposed
that's the rust let me take her to your
huh it's really bad
clearly the focal length there is no
macro shot and that's the first photo
woman crying I was actually
[Music]
so I know this is the end of the video
but this is how we shot the intro shot
much like my this is iPhone 10 video I
wanted to recreate that but with the
original phone so here was the business
iPhone 10 shot this is iPhone 10 not X
10 and now here's the same thing with
the original line
[Music]
I'm gonna take a few more moto
comparisons and see what this beeps
looks like here on the original iPhone
and the iPhone time I know it's so slow
look at that I can tap I can adjust
exposure guess what I can't do here
anything it's so slow you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you subscribe and
don't forget to hit the bell so you'll
be alerted when I make new videos and
you guys have any other ideas for what
you would like to make videos about with
this original iPhone now that it's
working leave those also in the comments
below I'll see you guys in my next video
bye do so many times that told me to do
that outro a lot ok so now it is edit
taking a picture of me oh my god I'm
gonna get hit I'm gonna get hit no we
need a picture ok alright your shadow
hands look gigantic
I definitely couldn't have picked a
worse place to take this photo like a
shirt
[Music]